une production du studio sfr bienvenue
aux sans filtre présentée par chris
miller podcast où on parle de ce qu'on
veut que nos invités date site super h
40 est avec moi doom plantes ce mois-ci
kiss me viennent de lancer une nouvelle
collection pour souligner la communauté
lgbt qu plus ils ont travaillé avec six
créateurs de contenu québécois pour
former six nouveaux pièces aux couleurs
en fait de l'arc-en-ciel notamment les
emmena d'eau que vous connaissez très
bien si une favorite du podcast qui
anime son propre podcast audio sf
bref c'est en collaboration avec mu
influence propulsé par peyo beaudoin
fait qu'aller voir la collection
lesquels sont vraiment hot et on a notre
code promo pour vous qui le sans filtre
pour 20% de rabais sur tous les produits
qu'ils me fait que garou garou sugar
rush et vous là tu diriges sinon cette
semaine donne cette semaine on a reçu
ses moncoutié qui est un journaliste et
arad qui est une élève frange un peu
plus jeunes un peu plus au web de
radio-canada qui font du contenu avec
extraordinaire simon qui fait souvent un
petit peu de journalisme d'infiltration
traître qui va à la rencontre de milieux
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir pour
nous montrer de l'intérieur puisque fait
avec m
sur dernier balado avec anna de
conviction il ya rencontré quatre des
leaders conspirationnistes le de ce
mouvement le cul beaucoup dans la
dernière année pour essayer de
comprendre un petit plus justement de
l'intérieur leur motivation ce qu'ils en
aient le leurs croyances pour ce avons
une approche un petit peu plus
d'empathie cas ces personnes là mais
sans toutefois donner du crédit ou de
l'importance à leur propos c'est
vraiment super intéressant ce dingo
vraiment qui qui qui qui veut comprendre
ce genre de phénomène
piste est vraiment intéressant lors
selon la caf ce jour là faudrait soir
des journalistes comme lui sur le
podcast
juste avant de vous laisser à la
conversation va les remercier nos
commanditaires fait que bon bac est oui
le podcast est présenté par vive qui
font des soucis ma foi délicieux qui et
quoi de mieux qu'un bon signe si frais
l'été pour se rafraîchir pis on peut
déguster des façons de plusieurs façons
ans mutti ou un smoothie d'eau mais
aussi en popsicle ou même en crème
glacée les gagnent toutes ces options ne
sont aussi bonnes et après il est sûr
que j'ai testé la crème glacée je vous
montre de quoi cela me fait vivre en
mode craint glacé fait que ce seront des
toc toc que je mets dans mon mixeur avec
une banane glacée qui est un peu de lait
d'avoine jusqu'à ce que j'atteigne la
texture désirée je monte ce su fixer un
prix trop vite le temps de changer mon
jeu l'est puis cette invitation
[Musique]
c'est la preuve ça ça le fait placide
merci arrive donc si vous voulez vous
aussi recommandé chez eux vivons un code
promo qui le sans filtre pas de gaz 10
pour 10 $ de rabais sur votre 1ere
commande avait fait sauter là dessus
avec un temps chaud qui s'en viennent
vous allez être surpris miam miam
le vote cadre 7e et présenté par memscap
vous les connaissez on en parle tout le
temps c'est les meilleurs produits pour
l'entretien sous la ceinture mais aussi
l'entretien de pilosité en général même
si l on veut te parle de landemont 4.0
leur nouveau trimer le look est ce les
quoi le prouvent skins et technologies
des grandes heures de garde différentes
pour mettre du style soit dans votre
face ou dans vos poils sous la ceinture
su mettre du style dans ce coin là il ya
aussi le we do hackers qui est un
wacker pour le poêle 2 n'est donc pour
garder ce bain clean le parfait mais
c'est mon parfum que je mets tout le
temps si c'est de la bombe pauvres et
même triple et produit même skype sont
extraordinaires moi je vous parlais de
lucho ce n'est pas quelque chose mucho
smoot parce que moi je l'utilisé sa
survenue quand j'étais enfant c'est un
citoyen doit vraiment se sent rasoir
vraiment le mannequin côté pas d âge
pour m'indiquer dans trois langues toi à
moi on ne trouve qu'ils ramadi zannier
pour la région le sous la ceinture
justement pour avoir le rasage le plus
près le plus loin possible
je l'utilisé la première fois je pars ça
arrive de manquer tom hanks était doux
tellement que j'avais aucune inquiétude
aussi de couper que ce soit le cg c'est
vraiment super super super doux c'est
vraiment des années pour ce est tout
petit en plus c'est super facile à
manier ayez des produits qui venait kz1
gel pour mai pour se raser pour m avant
et un exfoliant pour m
après pour avoir encore la douceur d'un
niveau divan diminuer aussi l'exploit
diminuer les risques pour l'incarner on
a un code promo pour vous qui le sans
filtre en un mot 20% de rabais plus le
chemin gratuit sur n'importe quelle
commande men skype fait qu encore une
fois car je voulais tu gueules
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je lis mon salut salut
salutations merci d'être le plein de
choses qu'on prépare les têtes aux
nouveaux posters s'appelle conviction
ouais on y reviendra plus tard
j'aimerais qu'on commence ouais je
t'avais vu plusieurs fois détendue dans
les pattes étaient au vert
je me suis déjà vu des reportages pas
aussi sa tante il fatto petit et
historique et journalistique mettons pas
pressés ont rejeté à la pige longtemps
un peu par choix puis bon c'est une
période peut-être un peu précaire le
ses fins fin des années 2000 début 2010
t
en journalisme ça faisait un peu mon
affaire ça me permettait de voyager un
peu partout faire du journalisme à
l'international j'étais à radio canada
mais si je la première fois je me suis
réellement quasi c'est lorsque je suis
allé je n'ai en fait je participe à
l'ouverture du bureau de kapissa simple
buzz du jour à l'époque yvon seulement
c'est devenu vice québec dont les
capsules baisse du jour
j'ai fait ça pendant cinq ans et pour
finir dans le bureau terre ferme et
malheureusement et maintenant ça fait
deux ans et demi que je suis à ramallah
laboratoire de journalistes de
radio-canada est ce que vous êtes une
gamme qui travaillent ce qui est
transféré à arad ou j'ai une collègue
qui récemment sarah barrière brunet qui
est devenu chef de pupitre
donc qui dit les textes ce qui t'est qui
était rédactrice en chef par une période
de
à weiss qui a joint l'équipe ya quelques
mois mais ce nom ma collègue brigitte
noël qui arrange à l'émission en kite
qu'ils étaient
journaliste animatrice avec moi c'est
grosso modo la même job selon plusieurs
ont migré vers urbania aussi du coup je
rappelle qu'en vice québec est arrivé
c'était vraiment un renouveau dans le
paysage médiatique au québec du moins
moi j'avais pas vraiment vu ce genre de
journalisme la plus je sais pas
exactement ce serait quoi nous plus
d'avant-garde peut-être donc
s'intéresser à des enjeux qui me
représentais plus fragiles
puis ça a quand même connu un succès
quand c'est arrivé varices québec puis
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui était l'élément
distancié à tort de se passer le
fonctionnaire un boulot en fait ça sinon
94 est un média anglophone
c'était 3 go
qui n'est je pense d'ottawa en fait qui
se sont installés à montréal est situé
tout au magazine puis de fil en aiguille
est devenue une multinationale tiennent
partout dans le monde
puis il ya quand même huit ans on a
ouvert le bio sa première fois que
vaille s'adresser au québec en français
7 tout petit bureau tout est vraiment
une poignée de monde mais j'ai
l'impression à l'époque on disait bon
difficile de journalisme plus immersif
les tyrans couvrir un peu les angles
morts cité où l'eau c'est moi je
voudrais le rap la drogue
c'est les sports extrêmes match et est
rôti accor perd ses nièces de cette
affaire qui font vibrer les jeunes du
monde mais j'étais un peu les angles
morts des médias dits traditionnels
si je me souviens chance me dis qu'il
est un des fondateurs de dresde est que
les jeunes t'éliminer nario en avant un
détecteur à bauchi tlv tpiy je pense
qu'il y avait un petit souci de faire
comme un phoque à fond on le fait et
puis on le fait de façon et merci on le
fait aussi comme le journaliste était
souvent acteurs aussi des histoires
donc c'est un style qui tient peu mais
c'est pas nouveau
les 70 mais comme 13 thompson même et
j'en voudrais qu'en vidéo skype ou
travaux vie bias au début c ou teinte
avec les gars de vieilles chaussures vic
sans aller dans un marché d'art ma
france air de pacs tant pis puis
tchernobyl puis testé la croyance
populaire réputé sous - tout reçoit de
radiation t c'est pas la sphère la plus
rigoureuse journalistique mais le mérite
de divertir
oui mais c'est ce titre dit ce n'est pas
nouveau mais moi je me souviens qu'ils
quand j'ai joué c'est pourtant juste
après une fois que je voyais ce fait
preuve que je rencontrais sa pitié juste
omettons je me suis intérêts partagés
les goûts y parle comme moi le type ont
montré qu'ils y met pas son espèce de
chapeau de deux journalistes de tifos
avoir le français normatif puis les
images toutes sont produites ce
téléphone quelques jours de plus naturel
de plus vrai comme tu dis le t2 les plus
beaux sites le système vraiment vraiment
vrai le temps ouais mais tu vois moi je
passais par l'école de journalisme c'est
une fête le cas depuis ses chemins de la
fédération professionnelle des
journalistes depuis super longtemps avec
la rigueur les les normes et pratiques
ou la déontologie a t on l'avait nommé
toujours est-il je peux passer moins
c'est ce que moi je peux passer par
souvent quand et radio canadien ben le
le chemin c'est en vo en régions
extérieures québec ou en région québec
puis temps peu formés à faire des
reportages avec le temps pips au pis ça
change le satan a changé mais c'est moi
je la sentais pas de l'avoir sur
mouloungui mais reste en course aussi
mais donc
c'est peut-être sa tête une influence le
parce que t'es chez moi car je l'avais
av ait j'avais moi je faisais plus de la
réalisation les cris avant je n'avais
jamais été devant une caméra le stockton
accident de parcours
on dit aussi des reportages justement de
s'étudier les journalistes et acteurs on
dirait qu'il n'y avait pas on dit que le
regarde moins deux parties ou que votre
réalité dépôt complètement gervoson qui
le journaliste comprenez c'est un peu la
réalité complètement détaché le titre si
je me souviens je me suis plus tard
assister à au site en rade métis était
donné d'entrevue avec la fraude qui sait
comment tu mets ton tu leur parles et il
était très critique quand même dur avec
eux opté confrontés mais chanter quand
même que de part et d'autre il y avait
un somme toute un job de confiance le
tir les autres étaient des confiance
quand même pas te laisser rentrer leurs
pizzas le reportage sur un autre pied
puis c'était bon pas même temps tout
était tettey est étais tu t'appelles pas
rigoureux justement tu es confronté
l'église dédouaner en disant moi mais si
les banques que je trouve pas des
individus petite école ouais mais après
si les banques augmentent leurs taux
d'intérêt parce que parce qu'ils sont
frauder c'est que mon équipe et puis le
cela va mener plus loin jusque là mais à
l'époque vice pis je sais pas si
ça peut définir un peu comme en rade
travail ou comment je travaille aussi
mener ce type d'approché empathique team
qui équiperont n'est pas sympathique
alors à thé à aux fraudeurs mais ça
demeure criminels mairie il reste que
moi tu es qui pour juger ce que tu fais
dans la vie aussi d'innocence juge pas
police le ferai pas
donc y est à ce prix cette approche là
sans jugement pitié aussi c'est un peu
de parfum pour la question de ceux ci
j'ai trop grande proximité avec mes
sujets avec mimi intervenants les
personnes que je parle puisque j'en ai
une parce qu'il n'a cité comme à force
de passer du temps avec des gens pierre
a essayé de convaincre de parler devant
une caméra encore plus à visage caché
si je faisais il ya quand même coupe de
tourner deux violons qui ont été jouées
à 20 mais on la met un peu en nombre
c'est à l'écran cette proximité l'appui
à mon avis c'est quand - chose c'est de
faire un peu preuve de transparence
quand je comparais pas de bullshit sans
rentrer un peu là dedans parce que tu
pas vrai n'importe quel journaliste dans
lequel tout comme documentariste
journaliste grand reporter de léon
courbe ils vont tous te dire
qu'éventuellement il ya une proximité
qui se développe avec un sujet c'est sur
ces images vous à proximité l'ajustement
nouveaux spectateurs des autres me tombe
sur prend l'exemple des fraudeurs est
allé rencontrer andré que ça prend que
j'avais accès comme si on est une star
qui était clos le tripy tout a réussi à
percer une brèche rentrée le convoi des
images d'eux qu'on les entende parler
c'était comme si comme c'est à grand
lahou vers quelque chose qui est que
j'avais jamais pu voir avant bah oui
mais après c'est quelque chose que c'est
intéressant un peu à culture de la rue
qui est partout si je veux dire pis ya
certains éléments de cette culture qui
n'est pas super content qu'on ait fait
ce reportage dans un an si ce moment là
mais j'ai une vie là-dedans pour vrai le
come stay c'est la pointe de l'iceberg
l'autiste un cliché de le dire mais
comme je peux pas vraiment expliquer les
techniques c'est qu'en mon nom c'était
vraiment le style s'étaient pas vus
ni ching pas du tout le tissu si moi je
capable d'avoir accès à ce sens quand
même certains moyens parce que bon je
travaille à radio canada puis on a des
moyens latine reste que juridique est
généreux mais c'est rien comparé à
risque à la police peut faire chapelle
de la police l'a donc ce soir je parlais
tantôt de deux games opentrust homme
seul ait ce que lui et quelques fêtes
s'il se fait tabasser afin que son
reportage sur six mois et c'était
vraiment massacre et puis est-ce que
tout déjà senti mes temps qu'un camp le
reportage sortait petit joyau un
sentiment de dire pas de est ce que ma
morale et grise mais est ce que
commencent à être reçue pour les gens
qui sont ouverts
en fait les gens qui ont des quais je me
suis rapproché pour aller apprendre
cette vérité là dans le fond ce ses
pilotes dire que l'on n'a comme
développer un lien de confiance parce
que pour avoir un niveau de conversation
qui est raisonnable pour avoir un lien
de confiance fixe une fois que c'est
fait il ya quand même une direction
nantes un reportage c'est l'idée m'est
on comprend les légumes on ne reviendra
mais les conspirations et il ya quand
même l'idée de démontrer ses séides et
la pinède pas de les exposer mais un peu
de lait de les montrer fily de rectifier
les faits donc quand ça sort est-ce que
des fois tu dis est ce que ma mort à
l'été
compromise dans ce processus le che qui
rend triste comme sony il y en a écrit
après envisage rétrospective je referai
pas nécessairement ce parce que ces
attaques avaient trahi des amis en 10
mois puis est ce que toi des photos fait
pas entre ce tome sun le vivais un
niveau élevé
ouais mais c'est immersif mais comme ils
vivaient avec l'agencé qmi a vécu avec
lui aujourd'hui en faisait quasiment
partie allait parler chez eux
dix autres et puis c'est une partie
c'est comme une observation
participative sur ça existe là en
anthropologie ce terme ne sais pas quoi
merci
il y participer complètement ne
serait-ce qu'en même temps la
consommation de drogue
c'est donc cesser moi c'est il ya quand
même une distance d'une ligne
c'est souvent c'est de l'or de citer des
sources pas d'amis comme donc
donc oui à ce après c'est je pense que
dans le cas de conviction les balades ou
qu'on vient de sortir on lançait sa dans
l'univers ce projet là puis je ne savais
pas comment c'est comment ça allait
réagir les surfeurs sur good le tjp tout
va bien mais c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qui est une patate chaude en ce
moment j'ai senti seul dans sa chambre
en janvier tout ça on commence à
travailler à latche à l'automne quand
j'arrive en tête doivent être
complètement off quand ça va sortir
c'est finalement pourrait pas être plus
dense le 6 mai
mais non seul celui là pour vrai parce
que même celui là je ne savais pas
comment il allait réagir parce que il ya
pour reprendre un terme un peu devenu
qui fait les gens maintenant dans le
monde du conspirationnisme et il ya
comme deux narratif c'est comme si on
sait là leur vérité puis l'ami c'est
comme çà çà çà çà se croise pas souvent
donc je voulais vraiment comment il
allait réagir puis parce que c'est
qu'ils mènent de l'autre côté aussi à
des gens qui je me demandais comment les
gens là réagir à savoir je leur donne la
parole il ordonne ce temps de glace
longtemps si donc ces tests est et un
numéro d'équilibriste d'affaires lui
mais puis finalement je l'écouté la
série pile données l'épisode justement
du pro des questions tout part de ceux
qui te font entendre au dessus par le
titre ici mais finalement les y est
sorti tout eu des écoutes mais je ne
pense pas aux quatre ans car je te
dirais que sont mi-figue mi temps nos
acquis au début ils ont reçus qu'ils ont
analysé puis des cabans tissu narratif
radio-canadien de merdy au ta ta ta c
ils sont où il fait le fait que les
tests pcr ça marche papineau chiffres
tout ce qu'on te deepstack comme jared
c'est pas ça ma job de prendre tes
chiffres il est partagé
depuis le début a pas de surprise là
dessus donc mais j'ai l'impression que
il ya eu un petit moment digestion puis
quelques jours après je pense après le
passage à tout le monde en parle aussi
on a ou comme j'expliquais un peu plus
quand comme après cher expliqué ge
pourront mille fois le projet mais mais
mais si ils ont entendu à heure de
grande écoute en tout cas pillon comme
fait ok justement de sept ans une brèche
qui était percée de seacom qui ont par
le dialogue à la fin du podcast puis je
pense que peut-être un dialogue qui
quittent amorcé puis je sais pas
et puis m c'est un peu j'ai pu aider à
ce dialogue d'autant mieux parce que
nous autres - entre moi et eux il y en a
eu un dialogue puis ils sont pas c'est
sûr qu'ils sont comme il y aussi cessé
la ton truc c'est de la propagande
gauche et de canadiennes parce que j
crew hamon a parlé mais en fait je crois
pas idiote que cette croyance et ça
c'est donc
puis il ya des morts pied je n'y a pas
personne qui me dicte quoi dire dans mes
reportages de force mondialistes de
l'élite du graitery 7 le tir personnes
qui donc c'est jusqu'à 4h mais il ya
plus de cinq ans donc c'est sûr qu'il ya
ceux qui nous sépare mais en bout de
ligne je faisait mouche c'est s'ils
avaient eu à être froissés il aura fallu
que j'assume parce que
c'est ça ma job un moment donné je peux
pas mettre en ondes des faits non
vérifiés je peux pas mettre un nom de la
nation je peux pas mettre un nombre des
théories du complot
en tout cas sans le dire que ça me
connaît et on a des normes et pratiques
journalistiques puis c'est important de
le faire donc on connaît le phénomène
des bulles puis le blagueur et des
réseaux sociaux de ce petit con est
toujours fidea ce qu'on regarde ce
contexte qu'on consomme tpiy rapidement
ta réalité devient telle autre la
réalité sur le réseaux sociaux c'est que
les informations auxquelles croit les
jeux de type i sa
c'est une boucle en avait qui sont en
contact se passe tu que le fai qui a été
en contact avec toi qui tu as trouvé
l'épisode challenge est quand même ça a
dû créer un doute pas d'ingérence pas
non non non s comme pour moi cette
question mais moi moi ce que j'ai
compris c'est qu'il y avait il y avait
des raisons en fait de se tourner vers
ses réponses le aussi que ces
questionnements le thé dansant sa
détresse psychologique financière la
pandémie la celtitude
c
cette patente le chrono virus qu'on
apprenait à qu'on apprend toujours à
commettre ces jeux donné comme exemple
je me sens vacciné le la semaine
dernière puis joli bébé et puis ma
blonde allaitent lunda pharmacie puis le
gall 10 ans on n'a pas de données sur
sur l'allaitement pile vaccins comme
unique à prendre mais je peux comprendre
que pour une certaine partie de la
population c'est quand même bien non
c'est toujours deux potes d'enfance et
mon bébé c'est sûr que pour plein de
gens ça fait par tous soient pas que les
gens se tournent vers des réponses
s'évader
là je peux comprendre un peu mieux
pourquoi c'est ça justifie pas
nécessairement comme de te remettre en
doute toutes les mesures sanitaires
parce que c'est ce qui fonctionne à
vendre un vaccin les mesures sont arrêté
de bouger de la gangue pendant deux
semaines on aurait pu le virus 5
cessez donc
mais je peux comprendre que ce que les
gens paient aussi je peux comprendre que
depuis des années un certain ras-le-bol
d'une certaine partie de la population
face à l'élite fasting vous nous écoutez
pas on vote pour vous pis c'est en
bowling vous pensez juste en faire élire
puis puis sté steve lartige disait jeudi
a finalement fait pour contre la
pandémie était contre lannion
libéralisme outils puis combat oui
notamment tirs jeudi mais mais
parmi tant d'autres mais mais
mais un peu de sous il ya plus d'une
espèce de ras-le-bol comme de l'élite
ras-le-bol de ces des institutions
internationale ces deux espèces de club
sélect qui qui qui a l'impression qu'il
veut serein l'iata qui sera repensé une
fois de temps en temps à davos qu'il
choisit de l'avenir de la planète
t je pense qu'on doit se poser des
questions par rapport à ça mais il ya
des amalgames qui se font il détient ses
locks année des théories en poule puis à
en dictant que d'autres études ils y ont
été on y est on peut influencer ni le
titre position que ce soit mais y
étudient truc super nécessairement par
rapport à pandémie mais des arguments
qui a amené des questions maqam n'ai que
des bons petits comme bon point sur tout
l aspect le trou est pas comme je le
disais c'est sûr qu'en tant regardait ce
petit à certains moments et peaches
parce que le cafouillage une grosse
gouvernement assez bonne masse cammas
deux masques si on ouvre on ferme on
ouvre on ferme ses pieds placés comme
acquis mais la santé publique avait pour
commander de fermi restaurant est fermé
pareil puis c'est comme si quelqu'un te
regarde comme citoyens des camions qui
s'expatrient com mais après c'est devenu
cliché de le dire plus mais c'est un
avion construit en volt et puis je sais
pas combien de fois j'ai des expressions
depuis le début la pandémie même aimé ce
temps presse at-il fac donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on porte et puis le
gouvernement l'utilisé h et celle d un
autre affaire en août ils le
protecteur du citoyen dans ma blâmé le
gouvernement pour sa gestion des déchets
h et celle de cépie et c'est depuis des
années mais on va finir la pandémie on
voit rien on va sortir de ce pilot il va
voir du monde pour dire des contes
arabes mais mais vous en sortir avant
les échos qui suis-je pas mais moi c'est
un peu même si tu parlais de ras-le-bol
des élites sepsis c'est le ras bol il
est aussi que cameron pour pouvoir
remonter les demandes qui fait qu'ils
étaient les gens de confiance dans les
médias de masse mais qui m'a dit t'es
mettons le gouvernement du québec le
team auto moi j'ai pas voté pour la caq
moche convaincu que la majorité des gens
qui sont là qui sont élus au
gouvernement ce moment ils font leur
possible le pi font du mieux qu'il peut
pour le port pour les citoyens pour le
québec tiges pas sûr que c'est comme une
vie de flic justement cela coulait douce
sur un ya surtout un sur toi pandémie
pitié même chose pour radio-canada de
leur formation qui reste du canada les
journalistes travaillent leçons de bonne
foi ils veulent rapporter les faits de
manal juste possible ses juges ont trait
mois des institutions jeudi c'est sûr
qu'il y en a de la corruption puis en
autriche jusqu'au dents au gouvernement
avec les unités d'entreprise c'est sûr
ça existe n'empêche que j'aime
personnellement tendance à faire
confiance qui est il des gouvernements
travaillent pour nous qu'il aimait de
travail pour nous le team a prêté josé
charbonneau
c'est quand même c'est sûr que ça ça ça
rend pas la chose politique si on peut
l'appeler comme ça
attrayant de bain ou ne sait donc pas si
lettres de noblesse innoncence et donc
juste la mesure comprendre cette
méfiance l'as des as vu leur des
institutions qui y vient douter ceux des
étudiants tout le monde en parle qui y
avoir un examen à faire sur justement
qu'est ce qui a amené cette idée là de
ne plus faire confiance aux médias
traditionnels puis par où ça passe cet
examen une conscience l'ubs cette espèce
de ou est-ce qu'on a perdu la confiance
de quand même beaucoup de monde quand
même
quand aimé sédiments mais ça reste
difficile
on peut pas ignorer une même site une
minorité s'est beaucoup de monde
puis on peut pas ignorer ce thé en tant
que société puis ouais ça s'est passé
du point de vue mais des médias parce
que mettons les gouvernements je peux
comprendre comme tu dis la corruption
dans au québec notamment le décès facile
de penser ce mais wes casse est passée
d'un média je sais pas faire honnêtement
j'ai une bonne question parce que je
pense que le mélange des genres ou cité
dans ce sens les gens les gens font
peut-être pas tout le temps en fait je
pense qu'on n'explique peut-être mal de
travail parfois la différence entre la
chronique
les journalistes sont factuels je pense
qu'il ya eu aussi ces comportements
journalisme honnêtement ça devrait pas
être du journalisme dans ce cas
chroniques c'est un style journalistique
mais amir et scorait cas de l'opinion il
faut que ça soit basée sur des faits non
et je pense qu'il ya eu plus au petit je
faisais mon ami jean martineau mais
attendait pas je pense qu'il ya eu dans
certains médias quand rôles récemment de
son nez tournée coin repos mal au niveau
de la rigueur je pense que ça
ah ça peut-être pas donné la plus belle
image à la profession c'est sûr aussi
que c'est parfois les journalistes on
parle pour les petits je pense qu'ils
ont peut-être tendance à parler pour les
journalistes loties comme a pris dans
notre bulle tu travailles dans longtemps
une salle de nouvelles ont été entourés
de journalistes puis tout le bal dans
une orange pire non merci c'est ça qu'il
ya peut-être un
peut-être un peu de ça mais moi je pense
que c'est surtout la espèces
d'incompréhension de notre métier pts et
c'est ce qu'on est là pour chercher des
poules à quelques journalistes apportent
des fois non natives comprends c'est
c'est stade pas une bonne nouvelle
est ce que tu crois que ce monde l'autre
rencontre et puis tout le monde qui ont
adhéré à ces mouvements
conspirationnistes le est ce que tu
crois que ça va revenir mais t'en as
qu'une fois parce qu'il a été on a vu
juste dernièrement avec les mesures de
de déconfinement qui ont été annoncées
cette semaine il y en avait plusieurs
que l'or leur chapeau la fête la hache
de guerre était de dire ça va durer à
l'infini puis a pas de doute à ce prix
le le boude est arrivé tu n'étais pas
tout à fait arrivée dans mes méthodes
celle au moins on a en enfin infecte
fait l'idée de dire c'est infini puis
c'est juste pour tessa c'est derrière
nous piquent des mettons ces
conspirations là un moment donné vont
finir par terme pas par arriver puis
poste produire en fait l'espèce de
prophétie qui va jamais se réaliser
c'est un peu comme ici ou là qui a fait
ces sauriens élections priori on se
passe puis mais le parallèle est bon
parce que le monde qui croient qu ou
continue à croire à sa prochaine perd sa
prochaine vers sa prochaine à ce que tu
crois que le mouvement
conspirationnistes va trouver une
nouvelle niche
une fois qu'on va sortir tranquillement
de cette pandémie ne soit je l'appelais
contre les mesures sans tapis mais la
face et que tu vois c'est trudeau ayant
acheté des doses de vaccins ont réservé
des doses de vaccin pour 2022 2023
ça ça nourrit le
du côté et puis après avant falloir
encore porter de masque à certaines
places c'est bien on n'a pas réglé le
l'histoire des vaccins si je veux dire
le passeport vaccinale le qr code qu'on
dit je pense le club
c'est ce genre de truc le sas et pour
régler cela dit moi je ne suis pas un
devin puis tout le temps une prédiction
jeu mais je pense quand même que le
monde qui était le 1er mai dernier qui
était comme clairement un militant un
point tournant entre un sommet dans
mobilisation je pense que ça va
s'essouffler parce que vingt mille
personnes ont vu passer des dizaines une
île comme ça les a tellement de moi je
t'ai la piste est impressionnant cela
dit c'est impressionnant aussi le 20
décembre le 13 mars qui comme il y avait
de tout temps c'est tout temps les
milliers le produit par des extrémistes
et des familles du coup très large aussi
qu'il avait cherché toute sorte de
mélange et ses princes est
nécessairement tout pour tout pour une
conspiration kitty kelley new world
rihanna dingue c'est vraiment jusqu'au
mail
mon enfant qui met son masque au soccer
ben c'est beaucoup sont restés pis pour
ceux que un amalgame quand même qui est
fait dans roue et puis c'est une étude
qui sortis récemment
j'écris là dessus sur le fait qu'elle
comme c'est 2020 était une année
vraiment un pic pour l'extrême droite au
québec qui mettait les mouvements anti
mesure centa là dedans
pich je trouve pas que c'est que il joue
beaucoup de ceux de la définition socio
politique de l'extrême droite dans les
mouvements de ces mesures s'entend mais
c'est pas juste pas du tout à mon avis
tu as fait pas mon avis à ce que ce à
quoi je pense que c'est ce que j'ai
observé mai mais pour en revenir à ce
qui va rester après moi je pense que
justement c'est le 1er mai dernier
aussi je me suis plus la date mais la
manne la fameuse manifestation dimanche
au vieux port comme les jeunes c'était
il y avait beaucoup de cause puisque les
gens s'étaient beaucoup rallier par
techtoc snapshot restera en plus des
plus jeunes
quand l'avez pas leur casse du
confinement dépit du couvre-feu au site
et je l'apprécié je pense qu'un
couvre-feu va tomber quand confinement
qui vont rouvrir les bords
les restaurants il faut ça va durer ce
mouvement en timide hausse en temps
parce qu'il va avoir encore je pense
avoir beaucoup de choses qui vont
demeurer ça se peut qu'on doive se faire
vacciner chaque année c'est ça se peut
donc ça et demande qu'ils sont pas
capables de gérer je mets tu penses tu
penses pas justement que tu penses que
c'est anecdotique
mettons les gens qui qui maintenant
s'élève contre les mesures sanitaires
transpo qu'anecdotique fait qu est ce
que tu sais ça fait mais en même temps
tu penses pas que ça vaut trouver un
autre un autre moteur de de révolte ou
de grandes mains éventuellement tout
simplement parce que titan tout paraître
trempe ça existait avant la pandémie
c'est cette espèce de ras-le-bol face
aux élites les gens ce qu'est ce
jean est à dire la mère du piston
dollar/yen c'est aussi là y avait des
milliers de personnes dans la rue des
fois pis celui dont il portait moins
attention
bah oui probablement mais c'était aussi
il y avait autre chose une nouvelle que
le nationalisme identitaire
aujourd'hui je souffre la pandémie
artistes et des groupes nationalistes et
identitaires sa base sa basse est
beaucoup passé beaucoup par ses contre
l'immigration irrégulière l'islamisation
autre hétéro mais il y avait aussi
contre le multiculturalisme trudeau
c'est la tyrannie des élites tirer
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup sont dans les
discours donc
dentiste et là avant je vois pas
pourquoi ça ça continue la pitié on
verra quelle forme ça va prendre mais
ils vont s'en trouver d'autres petites
balades ou change dans ce dernier
épisode pour des questions à
mais le guilly le guide est un
personnage fascinant et elle est partie
d'un ex de l'extrême gassmann guillemets
à l'autre le thé elle était féministe de
gauche
cette pipe in pipe tout d'un coup de
180° total puis prochain bâti media
center et subit elle dit elle-même qui
est tombé dans leur habitat quand même
assez drôle ça fait partie du jargon
c'est vraiment ça écoute et qui obligera
les trucs de kew puis les documentaires
comme faveur de cabale des trucs comme
ça si la pilule rouge c'est le grito
winning ces gens ccdh en cédant lexique
lé bon d'ailleurs su justement je fais
une parenthèse mais tout à l'heure tu
déjà fier sicile qui est qui qui part en
tout cas mais aussi de ceux qui disaient
qu'ils aient beaucoup d'aidé des
symboles de son tir et mettant de la
pile
bref mailgate une demande quand ça va
être fini tu vois dessus redevenir la
perte nette était de gauche super comme
n'en faut que tu es tombé tête ont pris
le mot je suis rendu à l'alerté neige et
découvert lui trouver notre sefag et cc6
com comment tu penses que qu'on s'en
sort justement de ce jeu honnêtement je
ne sais pas parce que c'est beaucoup de
gens vont vont comparer sont secs puis
j'aime pas ça cette comparaison le parce
que tant qu'on a pas
j'aurais peut-être pu contrôler c'est
c'est plus complexe que ça parce que
c'est un peu de l'auto en de tripoli
d'autres vraiment c'est s'appuie donc je
ne sais pas honnêtement je sais pas ce
qu'il y en a qui y en a décollé de gex
pas qu'ils se réveillent mexicaine qui
ont troqué à temps j'étais comme tombé
puis dans justement dans le terrier dans
la b3 ou le bain tout genre sorte le
10/10 réveiller c'est comme utiliser ou
si le même mais j'ai donc utilisé mouche
réveiller - est-ce pour ça que ces deux
camps de trac croise pas d'arguments je
ne peux pas arriver qu'un argument qui
les comptes arguments de mme était
biaisé ou des 6 août et sailly et il n'y
a rien que tu peux dire pourquoi un cri
parce que tout se fait partie de ce
complot nadjaf le disent souvent déjà
fiat que c'est comme c'est quasi
impossible de pipelines et études le
disent aussi le tome 2 de raisonner
quelqu'un qui croit fermement à ces
théories là ça passera par la famille
par les gens taureau puis si j'ai
l'impression qu'en ce moment il ya une
détresse lundi causés par la pandémie le
jeudi le s'il ya une colère piloter tout
ça engendre toutes sortes de changements
dans des petites de vie des revenus des
contacts avec les gens du sopi le monde
sont en détresse puisqu'on attend qu'un
large l'impression que même si tu
continues à croire sur le fait d'être de
que la vie normale reprenne peut-être
que le fait d'être un petit peu moins
fort chez tout être un petit peu moins
intense dans des convictions aussi basse
et société parce que tu quand je n'aime
pas le terme sexe parce que tu y sont
ils sont pas dans une secte qui sont pas
dans les six n'ont pas viré ce top
complètement non plus de livres dans ce
sens mais par contre je pense qu'il ya
un aspect
c'est des fois je pose la question à
malgré justement cette partie d'autres
choses c'est en venant ici que donc il
ya un aspect de ces couples comme ouais
c'est ça parce que n'importe quoi dans
vie que tu fais juste penser à ça c'est
un cauchemar
c'est ça c'est ça mais en même temps on
a été un peu vecteur de solim et
dioxines ans ans
moi je couvrais la wii la pandémie comme
dit que couvrir la crise le pôle et les
mesures ça le plus les mouvements quand
les mesures centa au début si on entre
en zone rouge de chatter rapion qu'on
parlait avec le personnel soignant est
ce que mon collègue frais de la clp et
avais je sonne juste jeu sopi même jean
bassères on voulait proposer d'autres
sujets c'est comme non non non si après
ça c'est l'oeuf ou la poule est ce que
c'est c'est le site le plus consulté et
de loin et l'histoire de radio canada
c'est la page parfaitement mon réel
fiable qui sur le nombre de cas en temps
réel mais oui c'est moins une fois par
jour
ouais donc voici je suis jamais allé sur
claude parent ait plus vrai que jamais
allé sur une opa de radio can mais comme
au quotidien jamais mais c'est ça donc
les gens avaient envie d'entendre
parrainage est donc là on a comme mon
nom comme service public on allemande
ses deux fils est de servir l'intérêt
public
après un moment donné c'est comme ça va
faire ses jeux sur tout le temps qu'ils
demandent si je disais pas mal grippe
espagnole n'était pas branché sur lcn
pierre dit
regarde je mixe et dans ce sens il
faisait leur vie le vin c'est important
parce qu'il portait si c'était comme on
regardait tous les jours la conférence
de presse la presse les analyses puis
comme celle et les civières sortir des
récépissés
même nous on a fait sortir au début du
premier confinement on a fait les ports
n'est pas caspar zoomer initialement le
sauf que on parlait vraiment beaucoup de
la cage vide permet on était comme chez
nous les eaux en photo alors on va
parler d'autre chose parce que c'est
même lourd pour nous le t2 comme
constamment parler de sable des mesures
tout le kit plio fallu qu'on vous a été
2021 je me suis dit il à déconnecter un
peu de l'actualité pas arrêté de
regarder ce bonheur puis d'avoir mon
commentaire puis mon opinion pigeons et
on devrait faire six épisodes suite
amené jeudi
au final quand même que je dise en deux
versions de refaire ce que j'avais mon
opinion sur le être le truc change pas
grand chose
loin d'un fake chinois dès qu'on ait
pignon est pas mal moins fort mais
quelqu'un qui connaissait mais en entre
ses métiers
on se posait des questions toute la game
métier mousse que sita tantôt justement
à propos de mails qui qui qui parlait
pas d'autre chose ça me ferait penser
machete chemise si j'étais une fin de
semaine son gain avec un but et puis ce
que l'on parle et non pas le série
netflix on parlait de musées que par les
plages offertes et puis à m'amener on
est tombé sur pas limite ce puits le
mieux j'ai levé les yeux j'ai vu le
ticket ibérique reçu le forum économique
mondial mène ce qui prépare petit jack
russell crowe sopi les écoles au le j'ai
vu que tu y étais tombé un peu là dedans
mais il reste est fonctionnel dans ce
sens que tout la fête toute la semaine
on a parlé d'autres choses seront le
théâtre à sin lun j'ai dû tracer une
ligne g resterait tout va rediscuter
avec lui j'ai pu t on une conversation
il ya eu un dialogue ça c'est bon ça
c'est cool mais moi j'en ai un ami comme
ça puis
et pas une ligne imaginaire qu'elle se
calme on arrête le tricycle cependant
faire d'être d'accord que je trouve que
c'est pas vrai ce que je me dis au moins
le guide si ils capables de parler
d'autre chose puis oui il ya encore un
pee d'accord à pied bien garé grande
aide en réalité puis un autre qui veut
partir c'est mais au moins y rattachent
à quelque chose l'ayez pas juste il fait
pas juste parler de ce jeu mais dit-il
encore et partie montrer qui est ça
prendrait pas groupe c'est un petit
quelque chose
ouais ça m'est arrivé je pense que tout
le monde à excuser moi je pense mais
tout le monde en haut dans leur famille
ou dans ceux d'antan alors certes dany
ça m'est arrivé dernièrement c'était la
première fois que ça m'arrive en fait je
n'avais jamais rencontré de ma vie qui
me consume hier à parler puis en une
minute dans la conversation me demande
était tout conspirationnistes puis le
match je convenais comme pub la question
venait dans quel sens qu'on voyait pas
si c'était genre elle même les tpiy
s'approprier le titre conspirationnisme
temps avec fierté d'avoir découvert les
conspirations mettant le pilot
finalement on a commencé à voir et plus
j'ai vu que c'est une pente glissante
mais au contraire de toi j'ai juste dit
je pense pas je t'ai pas un moment pour
avoir un débat je pense pas une bonne
dès qu'on parle de semaine mais c'est ça
moi c'est un peu là j'en ai jamais dit
comme ça c'est un peu la posture
conséquent alors pas trop là parce que
ses poches c'est justement pas un débat
parce qu'elle lui persuadé c'est ce que
j'ai moi aussi ce donc je cachais pas de
source et se sait sur le grand paradoxe
de ce qu'ils demandent souvent ces gens
là c'est qu'ils demandent qui est un
dialogue qui est différent pour une vue
que dans les médias traditionnels il ya
différents points de vue qui est un
chercheur d'un côté vers ce chercheur de
l'autre puis classé des gens dans ce bar
public pour faut pour que jaillisse la
victime et 1,6 et 99 % d'aidés des
scientifiques qui ont un consensus
quelque chose puisque rob de son bord
avoir un dunlop l'autre qui parle peu
représentatif présenter
c'est exactement ce puits mais on dirait
que c'est ce qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
comprennent pas mais après c'est radio
canada avec conviction c'est un peu ça
aussi que l'info voulait c'est vrai
qu'on n'aura pas beaucoup donné la
parole
comparativement à l'importance que ça
prenait dans les rues par exemple ce
mouvement pendant ce temps des stocks
nxt des projets le lieu
en fait j'ai été approché pour faire une
série sur les gens qui décrochent des
médias pilote à s'imposer con qu'on
parle vraiment plus de ce mouvement le
contre les mesures center parce qu'il a
ça prenait vraiment l'emploi mais il y
avait il y avait clairement radio canada
voulait faire ce projet là mais j'ai
envie de dire quelle langue puis comment
le fonds ont la forme et c'était ça
s'est fait avec les avec l'équipe parce
que j'imagine aussi que d'avoir une une
partie du duduk aux journalistes qui
disent pas sûr que c'est une bonne des
arcs ont donné la parole s'est joué
vraiment les gens ça a été
oui c'était si controversé puis
finalement je pense franchement comme
jeux détente où steve jobs
d'équilibriste je pense que son nom est
encore s'accordent de bull dans ce sens
que ça ç'a bien été
parce que deux parties de part et
d'autre j'ai pas trop c'est sûr j'ai
reçus comme de petites tomates le même
sinon ça je pense que les gens ont
compris pourquoi on l'a fait de part et
d'autre comment est-ce que tu choisis
les les personnes avec qui tu as le
tamis quatre ans c'était 4 plan au havre
mti comment comment tu es tu arrivé en
fait c'est un peu de fil en aiguille et
des bleus dit qu'il avait déjà couvert
de par sa pratique sportive de lettres
ou et piétine il pas aimer mais m kotido
remercions donc il y avait déjà un
contact qui était tia mais ce que je
faisais chez weiss à l'époque donc
pis lui était en contact des lives
montre les vidéos avec maxime ouimet le
policier donc l'immobilier m'a présenté
nous en ce moment je fais confiance à
hugo fait que le soft est gagné
cellartis j'ai couvert pas mal encore
une fois quand j'étais chez weiss tout
lé mouvement nationaliste identitaire
site online slameur puis et certaines
personnes qui me faisait encore
confiance dans ce milieu là donc se
tenir au portage donc j j'ai eu un bon
bonnes recommandations cela dit steve
était hyper hyper dati flottis ouais il
doutait parce qu'ils étaient comme moi
je parle trop mais dieu depuis un an et
à chaque fois je me fais avoir atterri
jeudi tchèque je me pointe chez vous pas
de kodak rien du tout pas d'enregistreur
puis on jase puis deux puis il y avait
des laurentides faire contre les
chemises pointe à sa maison puis on a
joué à dix pendant une heure et demie
puis
à 2 mai
mais donc
ayant embarqué totalement et même à fond
le jeu qu'on a un petit peu plus loin là
le le premier contact a été fait sans
enregistreuse conversation avec eux
autres ça dépend lesquels mais mettons
avec avec les autres avec un jour des
laurentides droit fait qu'étaler là sans
enregistreuses de josé pour rouvrir le
puits après ceux ci comme étant les
étapes qui amène de ce qu après ceux
enregistrés plage à des gens bien été
enregistré on a la même discussion
les autres sont qu'un caillou ouais
ouais parce que ils étaient en général
j'en disais qu'ils étaient contents
d'avoir le temps de jaser comme quand on
fait pas juste débarqués ou comme
chroniqué sur leurs portes illégales qui
ont fait en fin de semaine puis sans les
applis ou quoi que ce souci dans ce sens
je pense qu'en général était content
qu'on ait ce luxe là du tapis jolie le
luxe très chanceuse pour tous mes
collègues qui tient qui ont ce luxe là
donc
donc oui
lui aussi était content de stress qu'on
leur tende un micro c'est même si ce
temps le merdy ya comme qui dirait
ils étaient contents qu'on leur tende un
micro qu'il y en a pour qui c'est la
première fois donc donc ça c'était cool
pimmel pourtant mené mais gaulliste
accords joués loin c'est
j'ai créé sur facebook puis je pense
qu'en par facebook mais ou par téléphone
au sont pas parce qu'elle était coach
pnl avant donc à la version 6 de
conférencière et caetera et il y avait
son numéro peuple et puis peut-être
résistante
allez-y tu es aussi mais encore une fois
je me suis pointé chez elle
pis finalement andré que ça ça
fonctionnait tellement je leur parle
comme je parlais aussi le j'arrive pas
que mon fils a le plus j'arrive pas que
le croque un million radio cassé c'est
facile de dire que je fais un travail
différentes j'étais raymond je fais pas
aussi je croyais pas la même façon que
certains autres collègues me collègues
puis je respecte c'est à fond la caisse
le travail qu'ils font mais quand pointe
avec un cameraman qui porte un casque
une grosse caméra qui est un agent de
sécurité dans une manifestation
c'est surtout créé l'événement c'est
dans ce sens mouchon si jj la rdc d'un
skateur dans un quartier à
avec mon team qui a une petite caméra
puis on accompagne les leaders donc si
on ne fait pas pitié de roche mais mais
mais non c'est sa fac cc on travaille un
peu différemment on a cette chance
lorsque puis dalle dans le podcast ou si
ammann ni tu parles avec des lits des
admins de pages qui kaloutsky tiki-ming
ces groupes le teaser les illuminés du
québec pierre un autre personnage
dimanche bois puis aux hôtes de leurs
points de vue sont convaincus de faire
la bonne chose
ouais parce que on déniche les
aberrations les gens qui sont dans
champ's e puis tout a l'impression de
titres au programme les questions pas
l'impression que tu contribues à la
polarisation qui savaient pas comme
juste créé un fossé encore plus grand tu
es toi c'est us to tu penses tu que ce
genre de page le sais ce que ça fait
maintenant parce que tu poses la
question à mon podcast mais ben je veux
pas la question pour ouvrir dans ce sens
entre clairement fautif une chose qui
est certaine c'est que ça les convaincre
du contraire
ces équipes en les traitant débile que
conforama a écrit un débile tirage loto
raison oui c'est sûr que ça rique ont
répondu comptera donc ce sahara mansart
sommes pas dans le bon sens à ce niveau
là mais celui qui t'a que les deux qui
pose la question
penses tu que ça le fait pencher plus
d'un bord de l'eau toupin chez pas moi
je pense je sais pas mais ça expose t il
faut quand même un travail sur un
travail journalistique là mais faut
qu'un drap de recherche pour est en
écoute des vidéos où le piano risson
l'angle ty ce monde-là des militants le
anti mesure sanitaire
ils sont moi c'est ce que je leur poser
comme question de temps en temps on
parlait d'être comme dans une bulle peut
être obsédé pu écouter et des sports de
tir dans cette gagne le monde fait chaud
sur le télégramme le 10 10 les fonds du
monde des admins des pages qu'on leur
dit qu'on prendrait que parce que tu as
passé la nuit et coûte 1 12 mois qui
disent il est bloqué ces sorties fac
donc c'est ce que
eux aussi sont un peu dans l'art dans
leur bulle dans leur consommation peut
être un peu excessive des réseaux
sociaux puis mais je pense que sa prêche
aux convertis pour être honnête je pense
que ce genre de page le sais ce que ça
fait est ce que tu crois que ma tara
réponse mais que les réseaux sociaux
contribuent grandement à la
radicalisation puis à la halle aux
différentes opinions bien fondé ba
compte maintenant sans cesse beaucoup de
ces groupes là seraient pas ce qu'ils
sont on dirait que c'est quasiment sûr
ça fait mal grippe a sont arrêtés à
l'été dans la prison de facebook il a
été suspendu pendant genre mort
récemment
elle a par son porte-voix complètement
mais toi tu ce qui s'est passé est
repoussée par un appareil mais
un mot passionnel mans paris ouais c'est
ça m'est donc oui ça contribue mais
après un maul hors de question qu'on
pose est est-ce que la censure des
médias sociaux constituent aussi tu es
moche pas persuadé que ça marche du
monde de censure est quand même de
bloquer le comme des gens qui ont ce
type de discours là peut-être de le
signaler que si ces faits des faits non
avérés et cetera parce que censuré c'est
comme ça j'ai l'impression que ça
convainc entre que moi c'est ce que
c'est le discours que je recevais des
gens qui j'avais que j'ai parlé beaucoup
c'est que ça convainc les gens qui vont
trouver son contenu puis font partie de
cette grande halle un puits
et puis voilà c'est donc ça s'est
tellement c'est tellement taccetti parce
que la question intervenue qu'à un
twitter avait banni la ligne où je suis
sûr que si aucune compagnie privée peut
décider de faire sur la préface qu'il
avait une balle en mai mais si tu es
jeux de société reste sur la ligne et
outils le précédent et pourquoi puis le
monde qui étaient tes troupes ski
battleford et d'aimer dieu
et puis comment qu'ils appelaient
nombreux ont créé j'ai déjà oublié ça
fait longtemps que par là que tu penses
à tschopp les rayons les faits que nous
ouais c'est batel faire des filles
n'osent pas d'écho comme quoi les
médiathèques conclut iep la presse a
fait jeu sont dix raids le fait qu'il se
fait enlever sa tribune on dirait que ça
fait juste pour les gens qui étaient
vervins un converti trop mon truc ça
fait juste confirmer que oui est un
artiste ça peut juste confirmé que les
médias sont conclus et et oui après
c'est comme april le plus attribué ouais
c'est ça mais positif ouais sauf que tu
aimais tant et c'est ça je trouve que je
trouve que c'est au tce en crise comme
question qu'est ce complexe a nettement
pâti la médecine twitter autres dans
notre chambre parce que ce doit être
tous avaient mené à de la violence en
insurrection
donc s'il ya des lois contre le discours
et nous il ya des lois contre la
diffamation et si comme c'est important
le titre je veux dire l'ascension
existait avant
[Musique]
mais après ça je sais que c'était pas
dans ses lois le respect ça pour la
santé pour des questions de santé
publique je comprends mais je moi je me
demande si c'est pas un autre vecteur de
polarisation de les censurer
fred c'est comme ça ne me pose la
question
le souci c'est la censure cette option
mais télé
si la formule est aussi son et on
contrôle de ce qui pousse avec leur
groupe ce qui contribue à ce qu'on a
longtemps dit youtube les vidéos de
conspiration c'est ce qui fonctionnait
le plus patient mais on s'attend que
c'est une conspiration de comme les les
pyramides ont été faites par les alliés
en mai pendant le moins pire le cebr a
le plus de l'ordre du verdissement toi +
moi je pense qu'il ya du monde qui
croient dur comme fer aussi on met donc
tu y crois toujours concernant les
impacts négatifs la société je pense que
met-on mais c'est juste une porte
d'entrée dans la presse au sénat n'élève
pas pressés de le depuis je te comprends
sans les élèves plus confiance dans les
médias pendant le tournage mais il ya un
excellent pas de casse d'une otan qui
s'appelle de la b 3-1 puis les deux
premiers épisodes c'est l'instinct en
gros qui était tombé dans ces théories
le qui donne accès aux journalistes à
tout son historique de youtube puis
un tas de stock en fait lui aussi de
voir le chemin qui est empruntée c'est
fascinant c'est pire le je pense le 1 10
ce que ce que veut ce qu'est ce qui
amène ce podcast là c'est que youtube
ont été complètement responsable de plus
de tomber dans des terriers dans les
rides complot benedetti de la
consommation de pilules rouges ces sites
et après ça on essaye de défaire les
noeuds c'est en temps de pandémie mais
c'est un peu les réseaux sociaux qu'ils
ont créés avec les algorithmes
intéressant mais oui vraiment qu'à
l'époque besoin de se douter de l'impact
que ça arrête dans le vraiment le ton en
dessous de tout souhaité sert cole lte
au début ça sonnait comme divertissement
et cette envie d'écouter ses six mois
plus jeunes le jeudi je me sens mal j'ai
regardé une vidéo données les veines ps
qui na na na s'est tu pour générer ces
feux j'écoutais un besoin de te regarde
maintenant une autre commande et ça ça
paraît assez vite le palais très
rapidement quand et regarder quand mois
maintenant mais c'est masquer quatre
pôles fac tchèque cz d'à côté ça mais ça
c'est ça c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est
top mais tendant à lexie grey cette
trudel lui quand il écoute mais dont le
peter paul et tu peux pas vérifier les
faits à côté puis mettons qu'il écoute
avec avec un esprit ouvert et quand ils
allèrent convaincre qu'un garde à
d'autres affaires qui c est un bon comme
c'est cet anglais il dit si tu te rends
pas la peine si tu prends pas la peine
d'avoir des jambes facture qui skie dix
ou si la personne qui dit bang ses
affaires quelqu'un qui est comme qui
veut croire à ce c'est sûr que tu donnes
raison parce qu'il est capable de te
faire de donner l'impression qui sait
quoi il parle
oui en plus les gens ou entre les
instances où tu pourrais fact checking
m'a dit qu'ils sont sont faux c'est donc
moi c'est ça donc
c'est un trou qui est dur à sortir le
jeu mais au contraire de ce que tu dis
mais ton dans toc il ya aussi la
solution des réseaux sociaux dans quoi
il peut qu'est-ce qui peuvent pousser
donc tombe sur une vidéo de conspiration
sûr sur youtube puis que le prochain
arrêt comme dead c'est une vidéo qui
explique que mettons le pourquoi de ce
que tendrait d'écouté l'exemple des
pyramides
donc si les pyramides ont été créés par
les intéresse parce que c'est impossible
que des humains effectués dont tu sais
la prémisse de telles vidéos que la
vidéo d'appuis assez comment les
égyptiens ont réussi à construire les
pyramides mais status café twitter en
fait en ce moment
lorsqu'il ya comme c'est l'algorithme
détecte que informations non vérifiées
l'iag lakovic bavarois un avertissement
je pense que youtube le fait aussi
facebook aussi à mon avis mais facebook
est plus rapide sur la gâchette pour te
ferme et on compte dans ta carrière de
journaliste dans 4 mai donc qu'est-ce
que quels ont été les dossiers qui ont
le plus fait triper quels ont été les
reportages qui ont fait le plus tripes
et sco contre convient d'en parler pas
mal permettre conviction santé je pense
était le projet sur laquelle j'ai
travaillé le plus intensément c'est je
suis vraiment moi même tombé un peu dans
des vidéos tous il sait tout écouter les
vidéos qui montrent les luttes en direct
ou oui c'est comme était que tout soit
être convaincu scam charge n'importe
quoi s'est tenue à 18 ans et j'en ai
marre oui c'est la mère de la pure
merveille un truc mais comme par exemple
il est livré aux là il y en a qui sont
c'est tellement grossier
t comme si n'importe quoi puis l'autre
catégorie des films comme au top comme
ceci n'est pas un complot c'est super
bien produit super bien réalisé tout
dans ce style là mais ça ça c'est s'est
dangereusement gains réalisés en fait
pipi bien produit donc c'est comme elle
entre au progrès mais se rend compte que
c'est la bonne chose c'est qu'elles vont
ils vont en sens interdit d anciens prix
nobel
tatata t g donc cesser c'est bien foutu
d'en cesser
mais ce soit y en a d'autres où tout
tout ce qui entre un peu plus dans cupid
au satané spc affaires l'aude c'est 500
bébés mais ce succès rencontré qui
croyait à sa forme parce que j'avais
rencontré j'ai pas vraiment parce que
les nommés parce qu'on n'a pas trop
traité dix ans pensait on se concentre
vraiment plus sur les les mesures
sanitaires
mais puisque le niveau niveau qui n'est
que je n'ai pas de parler à quelqu'un
qui compte les mesures sont partis mais
on dirait qu'un et tu tombes un pack
dacquois qui comme tellement déconnecté
yuste ça c'était n'importe quoi qui où
le sénat sans sur 6 ou et l'anti jean la
pizza gates le génial c'est ce et cm
la connerie l'essai mais il faut les
jantes là dedans parce que vous voyez
l'espèce de couverts de genre on est
contre le trafic humain et le trafic
d'enfants
les gens ça n'a pas de bon sens qui se
passa pas ce bon sens qui se passe à
hollywood au parti démocrate qu'il
apprécie une chose n'a rendre notre
activité souvent c'est sur des bons
principes ou des bonnes valeurs qu'on se
faire bar qui fait qu'à par conviction
buy il ya un projet que j'avais fait
j'ai fait ce qui était mon dernier
projet chez weiss s'appelait cannabis
légal d'un documentaire du nord qui
marque et la légalisation du cannabis
puis donc on a suivi sa du marché noir
donc qu'ils ont là un 15 voleurs de
cannabis un producteur de deux
d'extraits du cannabis
l'aspect médical aussi mais de vue du
marché noir donc c'est un gros gros
morceau sinon un autre pas de casques
jets faux pas avant que ça plaira
carcérale qui était en cinq épisodes
d'une trentaine de minutes qui était le
lien intime entre une certain un certain
type de rap puis la prison puis par
ricochet la rue et le crime donc dans
lequel je suivais sur dieu connaissance
cazaux
fréquence wallez gretzky lost de 514 m
puis ça a été ça ça a été ça t'es cool
parce qu'ils sont aussi ces deux projets
là en fait c'est un peu l'aboutissement
de et
petit reportage que j'avais fait pour
vice autant sur l'univers weeds que
l'univers du rap puis d'une crédité de
convaincre contre 8,2 d'établir des
relations de confiance avec des dix
rapport à leur passion potan à pied
des talents du milieu du cannabis là
c'est quoi le lien on on est exposé
recevoir whitby dernièrement puis
finalement ça s'est pas avéré mais
j'avais cette question là c'est pourquoi
est ce qu elle est la stricte est
tellement un sujet riche pour autant de
rapport saville par ces normes et
mettons la question est mal formulé
juste c'est qu'on dirait que ce n'est si
tu fais du rap street
les thématiques leçons sont limitées
quand même le jeu peu d'accord c'est
parce que c'est pour ces gens là je veux
dire c'est ces gens leur médecin pour
certains certaines personnes issues de
la rue numa 6 qui vit sa pire je pense
que c'est pas la rue puisque la
crédibilité qui est importante
puis je pense que c'est la même chose
pour tous les rapporter dans ce sens il
faut que ce soit crédible dans ce que tu
avances dans ce que tu rappes et cette
erreur peut-être pas tous mais mais
il y en a pour qui c'est plus
métaphorique imagine multi même et je
pense que c'est super important
ce fait c'est un rap qui est plus
stricte ou cordes côté ou que tu viens
de ces milieux-là de raconter quelque
chose de crédible que tu as vécu parce
que si tu n'as pas vécu c'était pas
crédible ça sera pas ben ben non qu'est
le monde doit le savoir
donc ça me ça arrive pas ceux des
rapports qui keira durable la stricte
mais qui l'ont pas vécu vraiment je dois
revue moche je vais demander une
entrevue de djezzy qui disait que tout
le monde
exagéré ma 6e mais c'est un peu c'est un
peu comme lorsque tu écris un romain une
autofiction
sûrement cela cjrc ce août soit inspiré
de ce quinté jam a vécu au culte assisté
ou quatorze métiers plutôt une part de
ses soutes un exemple de deux rapports
que je respecte beaucoup sur dur
psychanalytique averti ses com cc je
pense que personne qu'il a pour les
contredire qui ont payé leurs 12 c'est
que j'ai l'impression des fois puis que
c'est juste
c'est juste une mauvaise impression
parce que je connais pas ça assez et
puis c'est probablement ça en fait mais
des fois quand j'écoute du street rap
québécois j'ai l'impression qu'ils
convainquent hampton à montréal c'est
tellement c'est tellement genre ce que
les histoires que j'entends dans les
leavers d'europe c'est intense mais ça
peut être intense dans certains
quartiers c'est la vérité comme puis
oui moi je pense que oui ouais ben oui
vraiment moi je pense qu'au québec on a
tendu la main en retard sur
l'acceptation de ce style de musique et
surtout le street art qui fonctionne
c'est loin c'est gentil seppi lien il
s'en fait c'est ce rappelé est excellent
aussi mais metz comme voyons légaux de
canicule justement 514 c'est
je dit cazaux sodja 6 et je comprends
pas franchement pourquoi ça mais je
pense qu'on les stigmatise encore on a
quand même on peut peut-être plus
l'impression justement ce qui manque ce
que vous racontez mais oui mais il ya eu
un succès il ya un succès qui en de
grogne qui me que par le web est quand
même énorme l'été justement ce que je
veux dire qu'il le succès mais passe
comme si il ya un plafond et puis il ya
perse pau le minstre insee le médias
plus traditionnels un peu plus
franchement si j'ai vu une entrevue
droite billes
ouais le nouveau le fil maintenant que
je vois ça colle tiges tel qu'un bon
c'est l'fun un boyau nouvelle cei ni
pour autre chose que c'est fait annuler
son show mais ça que ses autres gagnent
plus de la socan pour chaque s'appelle
on fouette ces foules c'est vraiment
injuste mais en même temps tu es je veux
vraiment mais vraiment sonné vu le jeu
est déconnectée parce que je vous dirais
même si j'ai quand même team et ont des
lyrics que je regarde des fois que
j'écoute plus je me dis dans un monde
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui où est ce
qu'on prend des décotes des paroles qui
qui qui flirte avec la misogynie
c'était de l'ordre mais je peux
comprendre ces méthodes sont des codes
mais à un moment donné décroche de tes
vieux code le tir parce que pittis
encore une fois je pense qu'ils ont tort
palais dicillo tantôt de cdd mais il y à
un orteil est du monde qui sort jamais
ouais et on ne sort jamais des quartiers
comme pin ou est ce qu ont ils voté
privilégie chez moi de soulever tantôt
que je progresse de concevoir qu'au
québec d'afro même se passe mais c'est
juste que je suis pas les laisser seuls
ils ont ils voient dessus pour autre
chose que
hayoun et m'apprend ou en fait je pense
donc mais oui et ça c'est qu'au delà
qu'ils sont profondément ancrés dans la
culture rap c'est moi j'avais fait on
entre avec un gros gros rapports
français que ça peut être car ici
j'avais demandé si la vague de boîtes
que j'ai reçus ce soir oui oui je
faisais mes luttes écoute sa réponse je
suis pas misogyne c'est comme sauter
puis c'est je veux dire c'est loin c'est
ce même esprit des codes et ses
thérapies moi je savais c'est sûr mais
même si j'étais un gros fan de rap si
comme je suis un outsider je peux pas je
peux pas le cacher c'est même eh bien
pas de l'autre c'est pas vécu le même
mais après je pense que dans dix ans le
sais je sais pas s'il va voir un
mouvement de kansai coacher dans le rap
mé
je pense qu'avec devrait passer à
l'autre vitesse moi c'est ça que ça m'a
fait est en préparation en entrevue
qu'il est supposé avoir et quads budget
petit son album je l'écris cdi style
bangle as-tu qui sont débiles et
règlements techniques et est charmante
mais diplômés mais ça marche beauté il y
avait autant de matches et quand même
c'est du génie knight link fait comme
home and what the fuck le témoin
c'est un grand a prononcé ces exemples
mais entre un excellent rapport d'accès
sur moi je trouve que mais ça ça fait
partie des codes je pense que ce je
pense qu'ils ne
une réflexion pour venir au milieu
carcéral qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils aient
mettons ce style de musique le pim et on
le milieu carcéral est aussi lié lié
mettons le sus situe juste parce que
parce que le blanc un plus grand intérêt
des rapports street parce que il parle
des réalités un petit peu plus crunchy
comme une curiosité ou ou le fait de
venir de la vue fait qu'on a besoin
jumeaux de sexe drogues et la musique
pour parler de nos réalités est un
prétexte pour parler aussi de l'aspect
criminel la chose c'est la prison mais
c'est aussi là le point de départ de ce
projet là c'est que j'ai fait le constat
que plusieurs rapports
c'est donc à the lost avait des
conditions de libération conditionnelle
qui les empêchait de rap et puis moi je
trouve que c'est une forme de censure
qui était complètement contre-productive
parce que justement tu regardes de ségo
lot c'est qu'ils ont fait du temps
oupoh passé ou qui sont dans un milieu
criminalisé
aujourd'hui le sait nous volent des cinq
dernières années le penser qu'il y en a
plein qui vivent bien qu'ils peuvent
finalement prouvé à leurs amis à leur
famille alors agent de libération
conditionnelle qui croyaient pas au
chèque pitié genre j'ai pu en fille
jeudi c'est sûr que je viens d'un milieu
défavorisé
tdes immigrants de première deuxième
génération ben ça se peut que la voie
facile ça soit de sortir un peu du
système ultime à ce que tu essaies d'en
sortir
oui avec le stress de ses selles photo m
a remis ce d'autres essences comme la
classe suivi de la musique puis tu
achètes un condo puis c'est peut être
quand même d'acheter ton hennessy mais
s'il a gagné grâce aux subventions on
cache t comme tant mieux mais en
discriminant métissé comme péter pas
moins crédible
moi je trouve que d'illégaux comme
sajjad cazaux c'est légal 514 c'est
fantastique ce moment avec canicule
c'est fantastique c'est des gars comme
si justement djezzy les premiers à lui
s'il n'y avait pas les cas de rapport il
y avait peut-être continue de la vente
coin de la rue voici qu'il serait
tellement lente est possible et puis des
justement des mettons ces exemples de
succès c'est mettons kendrick tous les
exemples incroyable le chemin pour des
jeunes de dire qu'ils n'ont pas rompu
on peut se sortir de la marde avec
l'ordre la musique latine au québec on
est rapide sa gâchette mais j'aime bien
oui par des crimes parce que c'est ça
existe c'est ce qui avait crié au bout
un serment du moins de mon expérience
curieusement sur notre homme parce que
des connaisseurs définitivement plus que
moi le mieux points
vérification du crime c'est juste on
dirait d'exposer là c'est comment bah
oui je faisais pas de ce moment donné
c'est correct je veux dire cessé ces
deux lors cessé la musique c'est celle
là c'est le mot leur mode de vie c'est
leur ancien mode de vie c'est entre
peut-être une clarification romantiser
regardé un reportage sur meego dans
leurs maisons testées comme la la
collection d'armes à feu kantigui
souhaite clairement il ya une fierté
aussi dans l'écrit donc crime le procès
colonna tendances et les [ __ ] et ce qui
est peu ce que je sais c'est josé se
sait tous mais c'est encore une fois
c'est une question de code dans les
cimes question de crédibilité c'est par
là qu'il ait prononcé pour maquiller
comme dee dee williams est imputé les
gars font le tour du monde ne doivent
point d'entrée de la rue en ce moment et
c'est quoi les autres projets qui s'en
viennent pour toi y en as tu d'autres sa
table où là c'est un congé de paternité
est elle simplement merci puis
oui il y en a d'autres mais
pauvre est reparti je prends bonne cause
que hans est une bonne rails le
franchement petit cct qui mène le
contexte la pandémie tout ça c'est sûr
ça a été vraiment un gros gros projet
pierre en plus c'est six fois trente
minutes de podcasts grosso modo à tisser
pas il n'y a pas de racheter ces ses 39
juillet écrit fac tchéquie c'était moi
c'était un bonbon se traite plus la
personne la portion vidéo donc où on va
on va y en a d'autres qui s'en viennent
mais
on s'en reparlera d'autres épisodes de
ce site en question
il est question que une autre saison une
collègue journaliste à l'automne pour ma
part je ne sais pas
j'aimerais ça y revenir c'est parce que
j'aimerais c'est dans l'enfer comme
c'est que sont ils devenus boys
ouais mais si c'est l'approché genre et
qui plus est est ce qu'ils sont
c'est anton par les lions s'étaient
crashés ils sont cent corps ça va mieux
depuis deux mesures sanitaires aussi il
faut se mettre ton masque pour aller
chez pôle moto ça va marquer c'était
quand même quatre questions à steve
justement tipi toi qui as a changé dans
ta vie tu sais pas ce qu'il lui exige en
plus qui est qui
la tâche est de mise à quai saint-jean
la ta vie ben moi je me sois faire de la
moto puis le poids de la moto que
m'étonner mesurer aux restos c'est comme
si cher payé par et ils tireront des le
phoque legault les manifestations du
soda grosse affaire pour finalement tu
aimé se faire de la moto petit peu moins
en face et on dirait que c'est
proportionnel symbole pourrait aussi le
masque très rapidement quand je posais
qu'elle se pose pour des questions sous
le masque était comme si on arrête un
masque gens ils nous grâce le masque
mais c'est pas ça le problème problème
c'est le gouvernement c'est l'élite
selliti donc si comme c'est
symptomatique d'une personne qui
réellement gros match et on dirait
qu'ils sont trop choix mais c'est dans
ce sens que quiconque ait fait qu'une
pandémie fait qu'on doit mettre en
marche les personnes tout cas c'est tout
le monde et grâce au kit au succès
gossip mais qui qui font ce qui a fait
son succès gossip qui refuse de négocier
quoi d'après m
bravo pour est pour pour ce je trouve ça
je trouve ça cool parce que on a entendu
cestayrols pareils qu'on n'avait pas
entendu mais d'une manière de manas
critique mehdi mennad apathique
je trouve que c'est dans dans l'optique
tout le monde dit ça prend plus de
dialogues m'étais je trouve que vous
avez comme quand même réellement fait
dans ce sens que kamal al écoute de ces
gens là merci sans jugement qui
ça fait du bien et ça fait du bien dit
je te vois de qui captent d'un sulky et
qui veulent de part et d'autre qui avait
pas deux c'est extrêmement tendu ces
réseaux sociaux depuis près d'un an par
être d'affilée photo josée indien ars
ulala l'indicé sont beaux et longs mois
pour vrai j'étais chanceux à ce niveau
là ça va bien jusqu'à maintenant
chauffeur secondes mais accord avec ma
collègue brigitte mais aussi à cesser ce
pas cool c'est un mot c'est vraiment
quelque chose que je trouve que dans ce
site en ce moment critique et qui me
pèse ce qui m'inquiète ccc seule espèce
de defossé de radicalisation de de tous
les côtés - 6 pi 2 du manque de dialogue
manque de nouveaux instruments de
d'empathie puis ça n'en prend plus des
projets comme ceux je pense merci merci
merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin j'espère que vous avez
apprécié la conversation ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe bien sûr p tu es a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs aux membres béthunois ce
que on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi de
la conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur une page de turenne et le lien
vers sa voix dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin